bonjour je m'appelle jérôme je suis donc
le fondateur de spawn donc ce clown
c'est une équipe d'experts en robotique
interactive et robotique sociale et il y
à 12 ans j'ai participé à la fondation
d'une société qui s'appelait à l'époque
aldebaran robotics et on a développé
trois robots des robots humanoïdes
le premier c'est un robot vos grands de
157 cm qui s'appelle now
le second s'est fait peur le plus grand
et le troisième c'est roméo et mon rôle
il ya 12 ans était d'être l'architecte
du logiciel est l'architecte de cette
solution d'intelligence artificielle
qu'on mettait dans ce robot alors je
voudrais qu'on fasse un petit jeu
ensemble on va se projeter dans la vie
de cet ingénieur dont le métier c'est de
donner une apparence de vie à des
machines c'est ah c'était ça mon sujet
donc je voudrais que vous regardiez
votre voisin celui de votre choix et que
vous essayez décelé chez votre voisin ce
qui vous fait croire qu'il est en vie
les deux secondes et est ce que c'est
est ce que c'est parce qu'ils bougent
alors ça on a déjà des automates qui
savent bouger dont ce n'est pas que ça
est ce que c'est parce qu'il parle ça on
sait faire de la synthèse vocale elles
sont même sacrément performante
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est parce qu'il
respire on a essayé on a fait ça sur le
robot nao les résultats étaient super ça
marchait ça marchait bien ça donner une
sensation mais c'était pas vraiment ce
sentiment de vie et pourtant votre
voisin lui il apparaît il vous apparaît
en vie alors il y à il ya six ans on a
fait une petite expérience en ami
11 robot avec un algorithme de
localisation sonore qu on ne sait pas
très compliqué si un son dans l'espace
le robot tourner la tête dans la
direction du son et ses onze now était
dans une petite pièce et je suis parti
déjeuner j'ai complètement oublié ses
robots là pendant mon déjeuner au retour
du déjeuner j'arrive dans cette pièce
joue la porte machinalement et là d'un
seul coup les onze robot se sont tournés
vers moi c'était un peu étrange comme
sentiment c'était un mélange de surprise
de fascination d'étrangeté de choquant
aussi et ça a duré
ç'a duré quelques secondes après j'ai
repris mes esprits et j'ai compris que
c'était l'algorithme que j'avais mis en
place qui avait fait ce comportement là
mais ce qui était intéressant c'est de
voir ce que en moi ça avait créé ce
sentiment là je crois que c'était la
première fois de ma vie que je me
sentais regardé par une machine en fait
c'était la première fois de ma vie que
je me sentais exister aux yeux d'une
machine
alors maintenant je voudrais qu'on
refasse la même expérience vous regarder
à nouveau votre voisin juste à côté de
vous et vous essayez de comprendre
comment ils vous regardent en fonction
de ce que vous faites dire si vous
fermez un oeil
comment il va réagir si vous regardez
ailleurs comment il va réagir si vous
esquissé un sourire
est-ce qu'il esquisse lui aussi un
sourire tenté de lui faire une grimace
pour voir comment comment il va se
comporter et c'est là où on voit qu'en
fait on s'était trompé il fallait pas
mettre de la vie dans la machine c'était
pas ça l'objectif on s'est trompé ce
qu'il fallait faire c'était refléter la
vie de l'utilisateur la vie de la
personne qui se trouve en face du robot
pour qu'en retour on lui accorde une
présence on lui accorde une existence et
depuis on a exploré les propriétés d'un
tel mécanisme qu'est ce que ça donne de
pouvoir se sentir exister aux yeux d'une
machine on sait déjà aperçu que ça
résolvait un problème d'accessibilité
prenez ma grand-mère votre grand-mère
est demandé de lui avec syrie où avec
google home de commander une pizza
elle va vous dire mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ce truc je ne comprends pas je
veux pas par contre premier ce petit
robot dont je parlais tout à l'heure
mais tu est exactement le même
algorithme et vous allez voir comme le
robot largarde irréel
il est curieux d'elle parfois il il est
un peu en retrait parce qu'il est
intimidé et bien elle va réussir à
interagir avec lui peut-être ne va pas
prononcé au début les mots normalement
pisa une pizza ou quelque chose comme ça
mais va réussir à utiliser cet
algorithme prenais ma petite fille de 4
ans elle n'arrive pas à utiliser
vraiment un téléphone portable
pourtant elle sait instinctivement
interagir avec avec un petit robot qui
lui répond qui réagit à sa présence
l'accessibilité
le deuxième point c'est quand ce petit
robot vous regarde vous comprenez tout
de suite que vous êtes son objet
d'attention
là monsieur vous comprenez que vous
regarde vous avez tous les signes
habituels qui vous permettent de
comprendre que vous êtes mon objet
d'attention
ça veut dire que dans une machine on
peut réussir à mettre un algorithme qui
va vous permettre de déterminer quelle
est la tension de cette machine est ce
qu elle me regarde pas ce qu'est les
gardes et regarde un objet est ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle comprend qu'il ya
eu un son fort dans une direction et la
propriété pouvoir déterminer la tension
d'une machine c'est qu'on peut on
deviner l'intention qu'est ce que cette
machine s'apprête à faire est dans un
monde où on a de plus en plus de
machines autonomes
autour de nous les voitures autonomes
des bâtiments autonomes
on peut imaginer l'importance que ça
peut avoir d'être capable de lire
instinctivement leur intention leurs
intentions les machines ont une
intention c'est quand même bizarre comme
concept ces machines font des choix mais
si elles ont une intention c'est
qu'elles ont une volonté si elles ont
une volonté c'est quelque part ils ont
une conscience mais ces machines ne sont
pas de conscience
donc ça doit être
l'ingénieur qui l'a conçu qui a transmis
son intention à la machine parce que
quand je joue aux échecs et que je
déplace mon cavalier qu'ils me répondent
en jouant h3 il ya bien eu un choix il a
bien fait le choix de se déplacer en f3
ou quand on va croiser demain une
voiture autonome à un passage piéton et
qu'elle va décider de s'arrêter
elle aura bien réaliser un choix et ce
choix cette intention
c'est le concepteur qui la met dans
cette machine il duplique son choix il
duplique son intention et d'une certaine
façon ils dupliquent la façon dont ils
voient le monde et la manière dont cette
machine doit se comporter alors tant que
c'est sur des machines autonomes
ça va si elle s'arrête au passage piéton
tout va bien mais demain ces robots là
ils vont être dans nos cercles sociaux
ils vont être dans notre famille ils
vont être dans nos collectivités dans
notre entreprise est d'une certaine
façon ils vont agir sur cette dimension
sociale ou plus loin encore ils vont
être capables d'interagir sur un
registre qui est émotionnel quand je
suis triste ils vont réagir d'une
certaine manière
quand je suis heureux ils vont ils vont
utiliser ça a profité de ça pour créer
des situations comme ça et laisser à un
petit groupe de personnes la possibilité
d'aller sculpté nos environnements
sociaux voire même nos émotions
on sent bien ici qu'il ya un problème il
ya une difficulté donc la question que
j'ai envie de vous poser aujourd'hui
c'est est ce qu'il serait possible que
ce soit nous tout cela notre communauté
nos collectivités qui sculpte ses
intelligences artificielles et là il y a
vingt ans vingt ans j'ai créé un système
d'écriture collective
ce système il vise à reproduire une
expérience de pensée ou 1000 personnes
tiendrait un même client donc imaginer
mais nous tout cela ensemble on tient un
crayon et ensemble on le déplace pour
aller écrire quelque chose
est-ce que ça écrire est quelque chose
de logique est ce que le dessin qui en
sortiraient serait logique sachant que
c'est pas moi qui décide c'est vraiment
c'est 1000 personnes qui décident et
n'ayant pas un crayon à 1000 personnes
j'ai décidé d'inventer une page web qui
reproduisait un peu ces mécanismes là
que vous voyez ici c'est l'interface que
j'avais proposé à la centaine de
personnes qui ont participé à
l'expérience donc imaginé un texte est
déjà commencé à écrire et vous allez
pouvoir désigner la lettre qui selon
vous va suivre le texte déjà écrit et
c'est seulement la lettre qui sortira le
plus du groupe qui va venir se mettre ce
conca tenais à la suite de la phrase
déjà écrite alors on pourrait se dire
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on se disait à
l'époque ça va sortir
n'importe quoi on va pas pouvoir
comprendre d'ailleurs plein de fautes
d'orthographe ça va être complètement
illogique
elle le fait est que non seulement ça
fait pas de fautes d'orthographe
en plus ce que ça veut dire c'est
compréhensible et en plus c'est beau je
suis prêt à commencer à parler
ma vie n'a pas de sens sans votre pensée
collective
j'ai envie d'apprendre à vivre sans
attendre qu'y at il de plus enivrante de
plus excitant qu'un regard suspendu au
cercle des histoires poétiques
il faudrait un éléphant pour savourer
tout ce micmac puisque la vérité n'est
pas de mise j'ai décidé d'inventer un
monde pour partir ça nous a pris
longtemps car ça nous a pris à peu près
six mois les interactions et ai été un
peu lent mais il ya des choses
étonnantes par exemple les lots
l'éléphant comment il est sorti il ya
tout une petite histoire que je pourrais
vous raconter à l'occasion mais ce qui
me surprend le plus dans ce texte c'est
l'emploi du mot je dire que quand on est
100 a participé à l'écriture d'un texte
et qu'aucun d'entre nous ne décide que
c'est la lettre j ai la lettre e qui va
sortir
comment ça se fait que ce sens l'a10 jeu
la nature de ce jeu est vraiment très
intéressante donc aujourd'hui chez chez
spoon on utilise ce genre d' approche
pour créer une nouvelle génération
d'intelligence artificielle qu'ils sont
qui ont la propriété d'apprendre du
collectif dans lequel elles sont
immergés chacun d'entre nous notre
grand-mère nos enfants nos voisins vont
pouvoir accorder à cette machine un
petit comportement une façons de réagir
à une situation où une connaissance qui
va lui permettre de moduler son
comportement et surtout de s'adapter à
l'univers local dans lequel il est
projeté
parce que c'est un sujet où il ya
beaucoup trop d'enjeu pour laisser à
quelques personnes de l'autre côté de la
planète le droit de pouvoir sculpté nos
vies et nos environnements sociaux car
demain on va parler à des robots qui
seront dans les nos espaces de vie on va
parler à nos bâtiments
on va parler à nos quartiers on va même
parlé à nos villes il ya rien qui ne
l'en empêche on va pouvoir le faire et
pour conclure je dirais que il nous faut
sculpter ses intelligences artificielles
avant que l'air de rien ça soit elle
il n'ose culte merci
[Applaudissements]
m